when people say that this is related to
Consciousness regarding the phenomenon
what is it that they mean
well it varies on the person
um that for me is a little bit out of my
wheelhouse per se I'm a nuts and bolts
kind of guy so I approach this topic on
I want to be able to research something
whether it be documents photographs
videos or material uh I'm a
three-dimensional physical I need to see
it touch it feel it if I can type of
person but others find a much more
spiritual aspect to this topic and these
phenomena they feel that it's not
necessarily about the nuts bolts proof
science or whatever it's more about the
experience the love the light the the
they're here to save us
um again that's not my wheelhouse that's
not how I approach it but I think a lot
of people do approach it in more of that
metaphysical way uh because that's their
experience that's their mindset that's
where they are on their journey to
figure it all out and and that's fine
but but you have to
essentially rely a little bit less on
science or a lot a bit less on science
and more so on faith and and uh and
again that's not why that's my Approach
but for some it is and for them it works
for them and and I you know it it's just
a it's just a different approach I think
to um to a phenomena that's still a
mystery to us all and and it's if it
works for them I support that it's just
not my angle yeah so they mean something
spiritual because when people say it's
related to Consciousness my question is
well what's not related to Consciousness
if you take your experiences primary
everything is related to Consciousness
including including a table
yeah and and the way the way I I took
your question was more of the
spiritual aspect of this those that are
finding answers within their within
themselves versus actual science or
again those those nuts and bolts that
I'm talking about
with that I think that there's a very
dangerous part of this conversation as
well and you see this a lot um I would
say more in the last five years but even
prior you know you talk about the
heavens Gate cult and so on and so forth
uh that they attribute UFOs
extraterrestrials alien life to uh
spiritual followings and then sometimes
very dangerous followings Heaven's Gate
obviously was a a mass suicide thinking
that a UFO is behind a comet
um you have others that are much more
cultish in nature talking about aliens
and and so on and so forth uh the
raelian movement uh is is one that comes
to mind that's been around for quite
some time but then you know you you
again have in the last five years or so
uh a much I would say
much more dangerous part of this not the
majority but there's a part of it where
people just uh believe and they
sacrifice I call it the I want to
believe syndrome they sacrifice all
logic Common Sense uh our basic form of
Investigation asking questions they
sacrifice all of that for the want to
believe and they want to believe so much
that they will make sure that you do not
harm that that you do not get in the way
of that and if you do there's hell to
pay they want to believe in what they
want to believe that there's a a higher
more intelligent life form out there
that is wanting to talk to humanity that
the that they're here to take us to
another level of Consciousness a a
another
place in the cosmos that we're going to
join some kind of cosmic Brotherhood I'm
not saying that's true for everybody but
that's out there those beliefs are out
there and then you have the debate of
good aliens versus bad aliens are they
here to save us from destroying the
planet and destroying ourselves with
nuclear weapons and so on or are they
here to kill us all that debate is
rampant out there that brings up a whole
new
aspect to this conversation which I'm
fascinated by but to sum it up why would
they care because if they are there and
we are here and they can get here the
likelihood of us being the only two life
forms in the cosmos is nil so why would
they care it's if to me I attribute it
to the Ant Hill analogy do we care that
there's an ant hill in the middle of the
Sahara Desert that it's about to go to
war with another Colony or a termite
hill whatever do we go out there and
plant our U.S flag and go we will save
you we're hiring we've got bigger
weapons uh we're much more intelligent
than you we probably can't talk but we
will save you I'm sorry the intelligence
gap between us and an aunt is likely
closer than us and a civilization that
started two million years ago I believe
that because I think that their
intelligence will be so far surpassed
our own why would they want to come here
and number one even talk to us but
number two save us does it matter you
know the only reason they would is if we
are the only two uh in the cosmos you
know if there's just a handful of
civilizations in this vast Universe to
me that's not even likely but you know
that's the only reason they would and if
that is the case
how would we ever find each other right
so so there's a lot of questions that I
think we have to to ponder here it's not
about was that UFO uh an alien spaceship
going across the Pacific Ocean uh but
rather we have to really drill deep into
a lot of these pressing questions that
you have to tackle if you want to
believe in extraterrestrials are here
you just watched a clip from the
theories of everything channel for the
full video and all its magnificence then
click here and if you'd like to see more
then subscribe enjoy